uh
let's go to u.s life expectancy in 2020
saw the biggest drop since world war
ii go to page five uh let's take a look
at the story here
okay all right so where are we at here
with us
all right so u.s life expectancy in 2020
saw the biggest drop since world war ii
ap news u.s
fell by a year and a half in 2020 the
largest one-year decline since world war
ii public health officials say wednesday
the decrease
for both black americans and hispanic
americans was even worse three years
the drop spelled out by the cdc is due
to mainly cova 19 which is
responsible for close to 70 percent of
the overall life expectancy
expectancy declined more than 3.3
million americans died last year
far more than any other year in us
history with cover 19 accounting for
about 11 percent that killer
killers other than uh cover 19 played a
role drug overdoses push life expectancy
down
particularly for whites and rising
homicides were a small
but significant reason for the decline
for black americans for decades
u.s life expectancy was on the upswing
but that trend stalled in 2015 for
several years before hitting 78 and 10
months in 2019
last year the cdc said it dropped to
about 77 years and four months
thoughts ah it got up to 80 years man
we're doing pretty good for a long time
like when i was a kid if you met
somebody in the 70s in their 70s you
were like wow this guy's doing pretty
good like nobody in my family like you
know
this goes back to kind of uh we have to
reevaluate the ageism and everything
else where
you know we used to think like i
remember when tom coughlin was being
ousted by the giants
like he's 70 years old that's too old
and like he didn't grow up 12 years old
smoking marlboro reds he wasn't working
in the mines since the time he was nine
we're all you know we're all doing more
later in life if
if we go i think it was for the longest
time it was stagnant at 72 years
now it got up to basically 80 at 79 in
10 months and then it retracted back to
77 which
i have to imagine has to do with older
people dying of course right yeah well
you can remember we're living in the
baby boomerang
right the baby boomers are dying out so
a lot of people are not
they're not they're not they're not
understanding that the baby boomers are
in that age and they're they're dying
right they're born in world war ii
they're in their 70s and 80s it makes
sense why in 2020
there's a drop in uh life expectancy
because
they're dying out so we had a
combination of covet and baby boomers
are passing away
i mean the math makes sense seems scary
if you don't know what the hell you're
talking you don't know history
but this doesn't this doesn't bother you
at all there's no red flag about this or
anything why why would there be
let me tell you what let me tell you why
because the three main points said
number one was well one of them was
covet second of all was drug overdose
so covert didn't kill me yeah i actually
didn't do anything
well it didn't do anything to me i don't
use drugs and
i have a i don't think that i'm gonna
get home killed by a black guy
so as long as i don't have so many guns
so i have a lot of guns so they're
probably they're probably gonna end up
you know on the other side of it so
so the thing is like i said so i i don't
feel like i'm gonna find these three
categories anytime soon so i'm not
worried about it good
if it doesn't affect you you shouldn't
worry about that's just the truth that's
predictive analytics right there it's
just math
right like three options yep pretty
pretty probably
i'm not going to fall for any of them
i'm good i'm good so what's your point
with that let me use this so you're
saying what
he did he didn't hear his question i
didn't he said does it worry you is
there any word flags
gotcha are you at this podcast or the
next one i don't know i'm still in space
with bezos
he asked the question i just answered
the question ricky let an expert weigh
in right now let me tell you something
oh my god there's a lot of things we can
you know banter about but there's
actually we're waiting for an expert
yeah exactly there's actually um pat
what's my business
uh uh life settlement this is actually
his business okay so my business
is like with life expectancy you're
you're in the life insurance yeah
because
you recruit agencies that's your
specialty you're a producer
comedian part-time nerd crusher
um ppd is a businessman entrepreneur i
deal with something called life
settlements and the foundation of this
business
is life expectancy i buy people's life
insurance policies off them
for cash because if you're ever familiar
with structured settlements how is that
okay relax really really really really
really
really
really
really
really really really really really really good
time for you okay real quick real quick
real quick just on that yeah i i
understand that business model
i just don't understand like why people
like you don't hire hitman after you
acquire somebody else's long
long question if you know byron udell
he's got a similar thought process to
you
however uh we buy people's life
insurance policies for cash today if
you've ever seen structured such jg
wentworth well 877 cash now you can get
cat
you can get a cash payment now for your
assets just like your house just like
your car just like your jewelry just
like your art
your life insurance is an asset but the
foundation of that
is life expectancy how long are you
gonna live how long are you gonna live
how long
so women live longer than men yeah of
course healthy men live longer than sick
men
healthy women live longer than unhealthy
women
it's all about life expectancy so if you
get someone's life uh
medical records or aps you're probably
familiar with this in the life insurance
world you get their medical records
their aps
you can use analytics to predict life
expectancy what's my point in all this i
know how long people live
the healthier you are the young the
longer you live especially with females
so in terms of life expectancy here the
number one killer by far is heart
disease
that's because everyone in america is
fat and overweight no beast and they're
eating like [ __ ]
oh damn i'm sorry you're strong you're
like strong fat you're not you're not
just like fat
you know what i'm saying like there's
not baby he benches 500 freaking pounds
it's not like he's just you know getting
forklift out of the house
um is that how he got a seat and he sat
on the other side
these two were fighting over the seat i
was like you know that that's his gun by
the way ricky has lost i don't know
maybe like 40 pounds
20 20 20 pounds shout out to you ricky
you look great
and uh shout out to your beautiful wife
back there number two is cancer
yeah okay so let me tell you something
about cancer i've so i've i've dealt
with this i've had a girlfriend cancer
you might think you're doing great boom
next thing you know you get [ __ ]
cancer
right [ __ ] that came out of nowhere yeah
that's something you can't plan for of
course
number three this past year was coveted
okay that was a blip in the radar
obviously life expected ain't going up
during covid why because people are
catching covet a lot of old people are
dying unhealthy people fat people dying
number three beyond that are accidents
people die because of accidents
okay car accidents you know you're
whatever i mean we can go on and on and
on
number four is respiratory disease copd
lung
whatever number five stroke alzheimer's
diabetes all right what's my point in
all this
um people are living long it's something
you always talk about something path
that actually he just
um i think you tweeted this the other
day
somebody's pat's getting a little
creative right here this is the greatest
time to be alive as a human i agree okay
yeah
like 200 years ago a guy named gerard or
a guy named ricky could have just came
and just
beat you over the head with a shovel he
would love that or shoot you in the
streets and and
uh where do you live again would have
been good and bakersfield
it's over now like there'll be an
investigation okay so people are living
longer than ever
do you know the life expectancy in 1960
in america
had to be 63 years old
correct it was uh 62 years old 1980 do
you know where it went to
69. 73. okay by the way do you know in
1960 when life's expected to be 62 you
know where it was in india
41 44 in india
suffer from a lot of heart disease like
i don't know they don't eat a lot of
meat there from what i hear you know in
2000 what the life expectancy was
in america 76. in india
in in 40 years it went from 41 to 62.
okay that's a twenty
modern advancement in in medicine people
aren't smoking cigarettes like
you remember the movie uh the show the
mad men and just they're smoking like
imaginations
imagine if we were all just sitting
right here just smoking cigs smoking
things just having the time of our lives
point is now life expectancy is up to
78.80
i think as people look we all know
people that live to 90 100 no problem
warren [ __ ] buffett is 90 what
how old is uh is he these days 90
89 charlie munger's 95 years old bottom
line is if you take care of yourself
and you don't smoke and you don't eat
like crap you could live to 90 100 no
problem
millennials and gen z are gonna in mass
live to age 100. that's my prediction
so let me ask you guys a question while
you're doing this by the way that was
very helpful without the data you just
gave
um blacks hispanics whites
who lives the longest whites yeah the
whites okay who's second longest
hispanic hispanics you ready
can you pull up this article okay so
check this out so browns have a little
bit of white prism
uh do control f coconut coconut no
coconut
control f72 this is march 29th
okay go down okay right there the report
shows
that while black americans live to 72
whites live to 78
okay whites live six years longer than
blacks but you're ready for the shocker
go to the next article i sent you white
privilege
in fairness though look better watch
this
however the life expectancy advert for
uh us suspending population 81.8
hispanic slip loss is the secret is the
rose company
did you see that by the way hispanics
live longer than
whites and blacks why is that why do
hispanics live longer i mean you got
it's because their women are tranquil
and calm and never fighting
yeah put away the knife
that's what it is i just uh you know i'm
gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna attribute
something pat just for my personal
experience for being hispanic
you know uh in case some like white lady
in congress wants to talk for me now i'm
going to talk for
our people because i know our people my
experiences being my people
um we we believe a lot in um um
home remedies right we don't we believe
a lot in that we don't like
hispanics won't go to the doctor not
much on taking away these from doctors
or medical advancements
um but a lot of things are solved at
home you know they're not
they're not they're they they solve a
lot of things at home
and they know flowers and they know
fruits and they know it's very
um you gotta remember a lot of hispanics
in latin america and central america
a lot of them live in rural areas right
so you're 30 minutes from hospital
spider bite a scorpion bite will kill
you snake bite will kill you because
by the time you reach the local hospital
you're dead so they had to learn a lot
of natural remedies
in a lot like for example let me give
you example if you have tooth pain it's
very popular
uh in one i know it's colombia but in
mexico as well
is to chew on a cocoa leaf because it
numbs it
so like a lot of like you would go here
you drink advil
right in in in drink advil yeah yeah
drink adventure
or drink tequila yeah drink tequila but
over there it's you you could chew on
cocoa leaf and it'll it'll actually
bring down the pain
homeopathic yes exactly so there's a lot
of natural remedies
i just pulled up the article that i
asked the question why do hispanics live
longer why do latinos live longer so
this article
this is a pri dot org article number one
it says
cuaren cuarentena yeah is what it says
it says one tradition
in latin cultures but rarely in western
culture is quite antenna meaning
quarantine
during this tradition the new mother
rests for after 30 days 40 days and
bonds with her child will
while relatives or friends handle all
the cooking and household traditions
someone helps
treat the mother how to breastfeed it in
her book cochlear implants
this luxury is nearly impossible united
states where there is no federally
mandated pay okay so number two
food aguilar learned that the value of
self-care through food when she worked
at cafe mayapan a mexican restaurant in
downtown el paso it starts ingredients
from a community farm aiming eventually
to source off so okay so natural food
that's one
yep because they do themselves family
and community this same philosophy of
looking inside
translates into raito del sol daycare a
learning center the daycare beneath
andrades la muir obrera umbrella
their female community members teach
reading math hispanic science to about
35 children in infants
they want to look like the woman help
each other okay so let's just say
there's a community there's sometimes i
don't know
it's going to help you live longer but
okay i guess sometimes our cultures
narrowed down to just
folk roik folk lorico
yeah what is that folklorico what does
that mean folklore yeah it's uh it's
well florida
was actually towards us as a dance it's
where the women are doing with the you
ever seen that yeah by the way quick
shout out to the role of your ours
on your hispanic accent in the middle
eastern bank i mean
you're you're doing you're firing away
we need we need more than that we need
the math and subject okay so that's that
anyways but look it's to be honest with
you if you think about that
okay if you think about that if i were
to tell you hispanics live longer than
whites and blacks
none of you guys said it's nice first
it's interesting if you think i don't
know man but i don't think it's
hispanics
let me let me let me let me know we're
done i don't think it's hispanics in
america
no this is america latinos in america
the thing is that also it's funny we
were just having this conversation with
erica yeah we travel a lot right we go
to mexico
yeah we eat what we hear and you could
eat double because the the chicken
actually looks like a chicken it doesn't
look like a turkey
right so you it's the kill of the day
it's called it's known as a killer day
right so you you eat what you kill that
day it doesn't go through all these
processing things you know
there's definitely something to that my
sister uh lived in italy for six months
and she was eating bread drinking wine
and she had lost like 30 pounds man
i was like how did this is possible like
i'm watching my diet nothing's happening
i'm moving to italy literally man and
basically
what she she wasn't like doing it for
weight loss but she would do she was
partying and like
eating whatever she wanted to eat and
essentially what what we think about
what we think it is
is the preservatives there's something i
don't know if i can pull it up
because i don't know the numbers exactly
but there's something like
the average distance the food travels
from the farm to your
table in europe is like 16 or 17 miles
where in america it's like a couple
hundred miles
so they have to add preservatives
otherwise the food will go bad yes so
the food in america
is literally made not to decompose your
body can't break it down
by the way check this out jesse jimenez
just gave 20 bucks and he said the
following
it's because it's rare for hispanics to
put out elders in nursing homes a
hundred percent
i was just gonna say that how many
latinos you know you see latinos living
together
pat you will get this owned if you do
that so the power of family 100
is the same one that guy is that guy is
100 correct you put your mom in a in a
home
or your dad do you're not you're never
going to the end of it it won't
we're so close pat that if i have a
couple of uncles that i know right now
they get older and their kids die i'm
taking them in and they're my uncles
they're not even my parents
like and that's cool literally
throughout the culture you just don't do
that my grandma i'm a colombian i agree
with that yeah it's not even an option
it's not even an option hell no you
white people are weird
my grandma 89 years old [ __ ] you mom i'm
out of here
about at 50 years old like mom you're
fifth you got to go to a home like what
the hell bro
my grandmother
let me flip it is the is the culture
also when you turn 18 go and figure it
out no hell no
they don't want you to ever move out
they want you to move in your kids
moving everybody down
maybe that's what it is because an
america american culture is more 18 go
figure yourself out
so because the kids maybe are like
listen you kicked me out i'm kicking you
out
right you've no you've never you've
never seen a punter in the nfl
kick a ball as far as my father kicked
me when we were 18. he's like get them
get out of here so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye